شكرا لليال اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام
مستمرون معكم على مدار الساعه لمواكبه اخر
التطورات بالسودان من العربيه حيث اعلن
الجيش السوداني تمديد الهدنه لمده اثنتين
وسبعين ساعه بناء على جهود الجانبين
السعودي والامريكي وذلك لاستمرار العمليات
الانسانيه واجلاء الاجانب مع ذلك لا تزال
معاناه السودانيين تتفاقم مع تواصل
الاقتتال الذي خلف دمارا هائلا فيما
تتواصل جهود الاجلاء بالتزامن مع حركه
نزوح واسعه للسكان من مناطق الاشتباك
اعداد القتلى في تزايد مع انعدام الامن
وقله المياه والغذاء وانقطاع الكهرباء
بشكل كامل
[موسيقى]
كما ترون انه مسجد بدايه السوق المركزي
تدمر نهائي كل الدكاكين اللي في السوق ما
في دكان تجربه من
قوه الانفجار وجي
نا تعبانين
يوقف الحرب نسبه لدعم الشعب وللمعاناه
التي عاناها الشعب السوداني
توالت المواقف والدوليه المؤيده لطلب
تمديد الهدنه في السودان حيث اكدت واتنين
من خلال وزير الخارجيه على ان الولايات
المتحده تركز بشكل كبير على وقف اطلاق
النار في السودان وان الهدنه الحاليه قد
ساعدت كثيرا في تقليل اعمال العنف
والمساعده في عمليات الاجلاء في مقاله
بريطانيا ان سفيرها لدى السودان يتحدث مع
طرفي النزاع لحذفهما على تمديد الهدنه
محذره من عدم ضمان الاستمرار في اجلاء
الرعايه من السودان من جانبها دعت روسيا
اطراف النزاع في السودان الى ضبط النفس
ووقف اطلاق النار
قال وزير خارجيه جنوب السودان في تصريحات
خاصه للعربيه ان بلاده مستمره في جهودها
لاقناع طرفي الصراع بوقف القتال والتفاوض
مضيفا ان جنوب السودان لم تحصل على موافقه
رسميه من البرهان بشان مبادره ايجاد وان
حكومته تجد صعوبه في الوصول الى قائد
الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو هاتفيا منذ
سته ايام
يقبال من
برهان طبعا من سته يوم حسي الاتصال
يمكن
وتغير في المحال وتمشي للمهال معين
حتى انه هنا في وقت
ما كان سايل انه الناس يكونوا يتصلوا في
اي وقت
رسلنا الجواب المضطرده رسلنا له رسلنا
البرهان
الرئيس الفقير نيابه عن الدول اللي جات
ماذا تضمنت مبادره المنظمه الاقليميه
المعنيه بالتنميه في شرق افريقيا ايجاد
تضمنت مقترحات مقتضبه لحل الازمه في
السودان
نصت على تمديد الهدنه الحاليه التي تنتهي
الخميس لمده 72 ساعه اضافيه
ودعوه الطرفين المتحاربين لارسال ممثلين
عنهما او مبعوث عسكري الى جوبا جنوب
السودان لاجراء محادثات بينهما ايجاد طلبت
ارسال مندوبي الطرفين الى جوبا يوم الجمعه
المقبل
الساعون للمبادره هم رؤساء جنوب السودان
وكينيا وجيبوتي الجيش اعلن موافقته
المبدئيه على المبادره
وترجيحات بان يكون الفريق شمس الدين كباشي
ممثلا للجيش لا تعليق حتى الان من الدعم
السريع بشان المبادره
من اندرمان مراسل العربيه سالم الهاشمي
اهلا بك سالم ثلاث ساعات قبل الانتهاء
المفترض لهدنه اثنتين وسبعين ساعه قبل ان
نؤكد اذا ما كانت ستمدد او لا كيف هو
الوضع الان على الارض
المشاهدين
بالنسبه للوضع الارض كانت هناك قد تجددت
الاشتباكات خلال هذا اليوم في العديد من
المناطق المتفرقه من انحاء العاصمه
الخرطوم نالت حظها من
مناطق متفرقه كذلك ابرزها ذات المناطق
التي كانت تتجدد فيها الاشتباكات في
الايام الماضيه منها ام درمان في تحديدا
مدينه ام درمان المحيطه لاذاعه والتلفزيون
عفوا وكذلك الجهه الجنوبيه والجنوبيه
الغربيه من ام درمان هي منطقه صالحه وكانت
تتجدد بين الخيمه والاخرى
وايضا جهه نفس انواع الاسلحه تستخدم حتى
في اثناء الهدنه يعني والبيت الابيض يقول
الان انه قلق من الخروقات وقف اطلاق النار
او الهدنه وليس وقت اطلاقنا في السودان في
اثنتين ثلث 72 ساعه هذه غارات جويه دفاعات
مضاده للطيران نفس ما كان يحصل في اثناء
الاقتتال الحقيقي قبل الهدنه
الساعات التي تكون فيها يكون فيها تكون
اطول قليلا لكن هي ذات الاشتباكات بذات
الحده ايضا وفي هذه الايام تحديث ثلاثه
ايام دائما ما تشتد حدتها في الصباح
الباكر
الى الساعه التاسعه عشره صباحا تقل هذه
الوتيره الى
يعني وضوح كامل بتصريحات الجيش وهل هناك
تصريحات جديده من قوات الدعم السريع
بامكانيه تمديد هذه الهدنه ونشير الى
الاخبار العاجله ايضا عن البيت الابيض
الذي يقول ان الوضع قد يزداد سوءا في اي
لحظه في السودان بعدما اعرب عن قلقه من
هذه الخروقات هناك في اطار الهدنه التي لا
تزال قائمه قبل الحديث عن تمديدها قبل
امكانيه تاكيدها من قبل الاطراف حتى الان
تاكيد التمديد اقصد والبيت الابيض يعني
يستمر في تعليقاته حول الوضع في السودان
والولايات المتحده طبعا على خط الازمه منذ
البدايه وبانتظار المزيد من التفاصيل حول
ما يقوله البيت الابيض
والمزيد من التفاصيل عن علاقه واشنطن بذلك
سالم الان الوضع الانساني لو سمحت على
الارض
الغذاء الدواء الماء المستشفيات الى ما
هنالك
[موسيقى]
الان من اجل ان مختصه
سانقل بعض الاخبار العاجله مجددا عن البيت
الابيض على الامريكيين الراغبين بمغادره
السودان استغلال الفرصه خلال اليومين
المقبلين اذا يحض الامريكيين الذين لا
يزالون في الداخل على المغادره خلال ساعات
الاربعه والعشرين الى 48 المقبله ولا
يتوقع على ما يبدو تحسن الوضع هناك اذا
البيت الابيض يستبعد اي تحسن للوضع في
السودان ويناشد الامريكيين المغادره في
غضون ثمان واربعين ساعه كان البيت الابيض
قال ان الخارجيه الامريكيه نشرت المزيد من
الموظفين القنصليين واعرب عن قلقه حيال
انتهاكات وقف اطلاق النار في السودان
والوضع قد يتفاقم في اي لحظه سنعود اليك
سالم الهاشمي مراسل العربيه من اندرمان
للوقوف على اي تفاصيل جديده في سياق
تغطيتنا على مدار الساعه شكرا جزيلا لك
لليوم الثالث عشر مشاهدينا تتواصل
العمليات العسكريه في السودان في عده
مناطق من العاصمه الخرطوم التي شهدت
اشتباكات بين كل من الجيش والدعم السريع
واسفرت عن دمار هائل كما نشاهد بهذه الصور
بخارطه المعارك في هذا المثلث الذي يشكل
ما يعرف بمثلث الخرطوم الكبرى في العاصمه
نتحدث هنا عن معارك دائره في منطقتين
نتحدث عن منطقه بحري وانظر بعد حيث نفذ
الجيش السوداني طلعات جويه وغارات على
مواقع للدعم السريع في كل من بحري
واندرمان مقاتلات الجيش استهدفت قوات
الدعم السريع هنا وتحديدا ايضا داخل
الخرطوم داخل العاصمه ولكن في محيط
القياده العامه والتي تعتبر نقطه
استراتيجيه يحاول الطرفان السيطره عليها
ايضا بمحيط القصر الجمهوري حيث تدور
اشتباكات بين الطرفين طبعا هنا
الدعم السريع رد بالمضادات
المضادات الارضيه على هذه الطلعات الجويه
وعلى هذا القصف من قبل الجيش السوداني
الان الى مطار الخرطوم حيث ايضا نفذ الجيش
ومشط مشطت قواته
محيط المطار كما نشاهد هنا بمحيط هذه
النقطه مطار الخرطوم الذي من اول هذه
الاشتباكات هناك اشتباكات دائره بين
الطرفين بمحيط المطار وهناك طبعا بيانات
مضاده بين الطرفين ننتقل الى نقطه اخرى
وهي نقطه الخرطوم بحري اي شمال الخرطوم
وفي ضاحيه كفوري كما نشاهد هنا حيث جددت
المقاتلات الحربيه القصف لاهداف الدعم
السريع في هذه المنطقه منطقه كفوري الذي
يقول بانه الدعم السريع طبعا احبط هجوما
على معسكره بهذه النقطه تحديدا حيث هناك
قوات للدعم السريع وكبد الجيش السوداني
خسائر هائله بهذه النقطه على حد قول الدعم
السريع طبعا ننتقل الى نقطه اخرى والى
منطقه اخرى حيث بي ام درمان اغارت مقاتلات
للجيش على منطقه صالحه هذه المنطقه ومناطق
اخرى ايضا كان هناك غارات عليها هي مناطق
قريبه من سوق ليبيا حيث تتمركز قوات كثيفه
وكثيره
للدعم السريع ويسعى طبعا الجيش السوداني
الى القضاء على هذه القوات اذا كانت هذه
خارطه الاشتباكات داخل الخرطوم حيث تنحصر
الاشتباكات كما شاهدنا بمحيط القياده
العامه مطار الخرطوم وايضا مناطق اخرى
كصالحه ام درمان وبحري وغيرها
لا اله الا الله
[موسيقى]
تدمر الحنه كلها في حاجه تانيه
ومع تعقد الوضع في الخرطوم اصبح الحصول
على صور تظهر حجم الدمار امرا نادرا وكاله
روترز نشرت مجموعه من الصور المتفرقه التي
تم التقاطها اليوم لاثار المعارك في
الخرطوم بحري حيث تظهر مشاهد دمار بشكل
كبير اثر المعارك دعونا نتابع بعضا من هذه
الصور
من الخرطوم لواء دكتور امين اسماعيل مزدوب
الخبير الامني والاستراتيجي بمركز دراسات
الدوليه اهلا بك معنا سياده اللواء
الولايات المتحده تستبعد اي تحسن للوضع في
السودان وتناسب الامريكيين المغادره مع
موافقه الجيش على تمديد الهدنه الاثنتين
وسبعين ساعه اخرى كيف يمكن ان تعلق على
الوضع الان بناء على هذه المعلومات
مساء الخير مرحبا بك ومرحب بالساده
المشاهدين
الوضع الان في نهايه الهدنه التي يفترض ان
تنتهي في منتصف الليل
اشتباكات في محاوله الاستفاده من هذه
الساعات قبل الدخول
طلبات الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وافر
عليها الجيش السوداني
لمده 72 ساعه بناء على جهود الجانبين
السعودي والامريكي ولكن قوات الدعم السريع
لم تقل بعد انها ملتزمه
طبعا في اشكاليه واضح انه الغيار والسيطره
غير متوفره لذلك
هل الطلبه الثاني لم ترد عليه وهذا الدعم
السريع الهدنه ومن قبل اتصالات الوزير
الخارجيه من جنوب السودان ايضا لم لم يصل
الرد من الدعم السريع ويب في اشكاليه
القياده والسيطره عموما
بيقولوا انه بيتواصلوا مع الطرفين سياده
اللواء المسؤولين الامريكيين المسؤولين
الامريكيين يقولون بانه عم يتواصلوا مع
الطرفين لعل سيد حميتي يريد ان يرد على من
يريد وليس انه هناك مشكله سيطره لديه ما
رايك
ومن الواضح اذا كان في رد يكون في رد زي
صدر النبوات المسلحه المراقبين ينتظرون رد
الدعم السريع في كل الاحوال على اساس انه
تبنى عليه خطوه اذا لم يكن هنالك رد لن
تبنى خطوه وواضح انه المتحده الامريكيه
غررت ان الوضع يسير الى الاسوا بناء على
عدم الاستجابه لذلك دعت مواطنيها
الموجودين الى مغادره السودان
فعدم الرد هو في في نفس الوقت بيعقد
الامور لانه الخطوه القادمه لن يتم البناء
عليها معلم يعرف موقف الدعم السريع من
المناشرات بس لا يبدو انه تزعزعت مواقع
كثيره في الايام الاخيره رغم كل تصريحات
الجيش عن السيطره وعن استقرار الوضع ما
رايك
نحن نشاهد الوضع انكسب في في استقرار نسبه
وهذا الدعم السريع لجعل للمناطق السكنيه
وهذه اشكاليه كبيره لانه عمليات المطارده
قد تحدث خسائر في الجانب البشري وكذلك
احتلال المستشفيات والاعتداء على
المباني والاسواق هذه اشكاليه قوات هي
تعمل على حق الارض وليس الاحتفاظ بالعرض
نحن نشاهد هذه الامور وبالتالي لو غثنا
وغاربنا عدم الرد على المراشدات
وهذا التشتت للقوات هذا يعني ان هنالك خلل
موجود سواء كان خل القياده وسيطر او خلل
تمسك بمواقع
ولكن لا يبدو حتى الان بانه مبادره
الايجاد حتى في منها امل يعني مع كلام
البيت الابيض الان للاسف التشاؤم يخيم على
الموقف
الامريكيه تتحدث بناء على التقارير من
سفارتها وبناء على دكادير لوفاه اثنين من
الامريكيين الرعايه الامريكيين الايجاد
تفهم النفسيات
لديها عبارات افقيه واضح انه في اتصالات
تمت مساله حضور الرؤساء الثلاثه رئيس
جبرتي والجنوب السودان وكينيا محسوبه فقط
بجاهزيه المطار او مناطق اخرى هذه الحضور
عموما حتى مجلس الامن ترك الامر لمجلس
السجن والامن الافريقي باعتبار انه الاخضر
ويجي تجاوب من السودان ومن الدعم السريع
وبالتالي انا اعتقد انه مبادره مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
بيكون لها اليد الطولة في وقف هذا النزاع
هل يعني باعتقادك هناك وجوهات نظر كي لا
نقول انقسام في في داخل الجيش بمعنى انه
ضباط يريدون توجيه الامور بشكل معين وضباط
مقابل ضباط اخرين يريدون توجيه الامور
بطريقه اخرى خاصه مع المعلومات التي
نفدتها وزاره الدفاع عن مغادره وزير
الدفاع الى مسقط راسه
نحن نراقب التصريحات تصدر من مصدر واحد
ونحلل وبناء على المصدر الواحد يعني ان
هنالك انتظام في البيانات يعني ان هنالك
خطط يتم تنفيذها وليست هنالك اي مؤشرات
لوجود حتى المعلومات التي يمكن نشرت عن
انه وزير الدفاع ذهب الى مسقط راسه
معلومات غير صحيحه وتم نفيها والرجل موجود
ويشارك في كل
الخطط وفي كل التحضيرات التي يتم تنفيذها
على الارض الواقع
ابقى معنا سياده اللواء الدكتور امين
اسماعيل مجدوب سنعود اليك بعد قليل
[موسيقى]
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه ان المملكه
تمكنت مساء اليوم من اجلاء 200 شخص من
رعايه دول الشقيقه والصديقه من السودان
الى جده واضافت الخارجيه السعوديه ان
اجماليه من تم اجلائهم من السودان منذ بدء
العمليات وصل الى نحو
2744 شخصا منهم 119 سعوديا اما الباقون
فمن 76 جنسيه واكدت السعوديه ان الاشخاص
الذين تم اجلائهم اليوم هم من امريكا ومصر
والبحرين والصومال ولبنان وافغانستان
وفلسطين وغامبيا ونيجيريا وباكستان وكندا
وتايلاندا على ضهر السفينه جلاله الملك
الرياض العربيه تواكب وصول رعايه القادمين
من السودان هذه السفينه التي تحمل على
متنها اكثر من 200 شخص وصلت للتو الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
وهي وقفت بالفعل بشكل تام وها هي هذه
اللحظات الان في انتظار النزول الرعايه
لكن هناك بروتوكول بحري معروف لدى القوات
اي او اي قوه بحريه هي بصعود قائد الاسطول
ويحيي الطاقم الملاحي للسفينه ويحييهم
ايضا لوصوله او سلامه وصولهم وعلى الانجاز
الذي حققه اذا ايضا ننقل الصوره من الجهه
الاخرى وهي سوره
وصول الرعايه الذين وصلوا من جنسيات
مختلفه اسيويه وكذلك افريقيه وايضا بعض
الجنسيات الاوروبيه التي وصلت على هذه
اللحظات وهم قادمين بومبورت سودان
وهي سفينه قد غادرت ليله امس ووصلت في هذه
اللحظات
الى ذلك اعلنت مصر ان الجهود المبذوله
لتسهيل عبور النازحين من الاراضي
السودانيه اسفرت عن النجاح في تسهيل عبور
اكثر من 16 الف شخص من غير المصريين الى
داخل الاراضي المصريه حتى اليوم اغلبهم من
السودانيين الذين بلغ عددهم 14 الف مواطن
فروا من المناطق التي تشهد مواجهات وتشهد
اعمال عنف بالاضافه الى اكثر من 2000
اجنبي من 50 دوله وست منظمات دوليه
معبر ارجين البري يفصل بين الحدود المصريه
والسودانيه افتتح سبتمبر عام 2016 لنقل
البضائع والركاب يقع على مسافه 850
كيلومترا شمالي الخرطوم يستوعب سبعه الاف
وخمسمائه مسافر يوميا واكثر من ثلاثمائه
شاحنه بات يمثل طوق نجاه للفرين من
اشتباكات السودان عبر منه الالاف من
السودانيين والمصريين هربا من القتال بعد
اجتياز المعبر يتجه المسافرون الى مدينه
اسوان الوصول اليه يتطلب رحله محفوفه
بالمتاعب تستغرق نصف يوم للوصول اليه من
الخرطوم ومده مماثله للعبور الى اسوان
ونظرا لصعوبه الوضع في السودان سمح
للسودانيين بعبوره بلا تاشيره مسبقه
دعت اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر في
السودان اطراف الصراعي لتسهيل عمل
المنظمات الاغاثيه وحركه العاملين في
القطاع الطبي داخل البلاد وحذر مدير
الاعلام في اللجنه في تصريحات للعربيه من
خطوره الوضع الانساني بسبب نقص المستلزمات
الطبيه والمياه والكهرباء
اود ان اغتني مع هذه الفرصه ونتحدث على
شاشتكم يدعو كافه الاطراف هو الطرفي صراع
لتيسير عمل المنظمات الانسانيه
وكذلك حركه العاملين في القطاع الصحي حتى
يستطيعوا الوصول الى المستشفيات وتقديم
الرعايه الصحيه كما ادعوهم لتيسير اولئك
الذين يبحثون عن المياه
التوفير الكهرباء هناك حاجه لصيانه محطات
المياه والكهرباء واذا لم يتمكن
السودانيون من
الاعتناء بمتطلبات
الصيانه لمحطات الكهرباء
في ارجاء متعدده من الخرطوم وكذلك المدن
المتضرره بالقتال
وخطر جديد يزيد من تعقيد الوضع في السودان
منظمه الصحه العالميه حذرت من خطر انتشار
فيروسات قاتله من مختبر صحي قريب من مناطق
الاشتباكات في الخرطوم
المعمل القومي للصحه العامه في الخرطوم
الذي يقع على بعد امتار من القياده العامه
للجيش التي تشهد اشتباكات مسلحه متكرره
خلال الايام الاخيره المعمل اصبح مصدر قلق
على المستوى الدولي حيث اعلنت منظمه الصحه
العالميه على لسان المدير التنفيذي لاداره
الطوارئ بها الدكتور مايكل راين ان الفرق
الميدانيه تقيم الوضع
الخطوره تكمن في احتواء المعمل على عينات
من فيروسات وبكتيريا خطيره كالحصبه
والكوليرا والتي اذا ما انتشرت في الظروف
الصحيه الحاليه
ستتسبب في كارثه لن يستطيع اي من الاطراف
المتصارعه علاجها هناك شحف المستلزمات
الطبيه والادويه
والعاملين في القطاع الصحي يمكن ان
يتحركوا بامان من منازلهم الى
المستشفيات المدير العام للمنظمه الامميه
حذر من انه في حال حصول كارثه بسبب المعمل
البايولوجي فان المرافق الصحيه لن يكون
بمقدورها استيعاب مصابين
30% فقط من مستشفيات الخرطوم تعمل في ظروف
ماساويه ولن تستطيع التعامل مع اي تسرب
فيروسي في حال وقوع المعمل القومي في ايد
غير امينه
كثير من المستشفيات التي خرجت يعني الخدمه
والسبب يعود لانعدام الموظفين والعاملين
والمستلزمات الطبيه ما يزيد الوضع خطوره
هو قرب المعمل القومي للصحه العامه من
مناطق ذات كثافه سكانيه عاليه انسنا
الماسي العربيه
عبر الاهالي في مدينه اندرمان عن مخاوفها
حقيقيه من استمرار عمليات السلب والنهب
بسبب الاقتتال الدائر بين قوات الجيش
والدعم السريعه واظهرت لقطات فيديو خاصه
بالعربيه مشاهد تظهر اغلاق المحل التجاريه
في الاسواق الرئيسه مع اعاده فتح عدد قليل
منها وسط حظر شديد فيما يطالب الاهالي
الحكومه بتوفير الحمايه اللازمه وتامين
حياه السكان في ام درمان ووقف اعمال العنف
واي شارع فيها
شغالين شغل مره كسر الدكاكيف
والقله منتهيه مره كثير
كلها مقفله العالم
لاضرب بعكاكيز جميع السوق يعني الناس ما
قدرت تتعايش كله ما قادر تاكل ما تتواصل
المويه قاطعه الكهرباء قاطعه
لكن الوضع سيء سيء للدرجه بعيده خلاص
الله
لنا
الخميس وما معروف تشتغل ولا ما تشتغل
عربيتين ثلاثه يقفلوها
الساعه 2:00
يعني الواحد ينام
ما في ما في موارد ما في موارد ما في اي
حاجه بضاعه جديده خالصه ما في دقيق بيجي
ما في حاجه هسه حاليا في الوقت الحالي ده
اسال الله يا اخي ارفع
ما زال الدمار والموت يخيمان على السودان
اثرى المعارك المستمره بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريعه تداعيات الحرب تلقي بظلالها
ايضا على التجار واصحاب المياومات بعد
توقفهم تماما عن العمل
سماء لا تهدا
وجدران بيت لا تستر زارتهم قذيفه
دمرت في طريقها ما استطاعت وتركت شظاياها
اثرا
رصاصات ايضا لم تبخل على المكان كارثه
خلفت وفاه شهد اهلها على وقوعها بل الرئيس
يا ريش الريش ده طوال خش على المطبخ
يعني لحظات الاخيره
موت في لحظه كما الفقد وقع على هؤلاء
الاطفال
توفيت والدتهم امام اعينهم يتفقدون ما حل
بمنزلهم او ما خلفته الحرب على طفولتهم
اختار اهل الدار البقاء فلا خيار للنزوح
على بعد مسافه دمار لم يبقي شيئا خراب على
مد البصر كارثه بالدليل قذيفه حرقت
الممتلكات هنا وهشمت ابواب الرزق
قوه الانفجار كل الدكاكين ده ابوابها
انكمشت وتحشمت من فوق يعني ما في حاجه
اصحاب المهن اليدويه يشكون حالهم يحتجون
امام نقابتهم لا يجمعهم هنا سوى البطاله
الان وادوات جمدتها الحرب ووضعتهم بين
فكيها
الناس دي كلها سافرت مرقت هجرت مرقت لكن
الدول
مجاعه قد تطال الجميع استيراد الاحتياجات
الغذائيه توقف اما المخزون الحكومي فيشك
على الانتهاء وفق الامن الغذائي السوداني
مقومات الحياه ان توفرت حاليا فاسعارها
مضاعفه
معارك حرمتهم من حركه تجاريه كان يعتاش
عليها السودان المنهك اقتصاديا اصلا غيداء
السالم العربيه
نعود الى الخرطوم مع اللواء دكتور امين
اسماعيل مزدوب الخبير الامني والاستراتيجي
بمركز دراسات الدوليه اهلا بك مجددا اذا
الجيش السوداني يقول ان الهدنه تم خرقها
لليوم الثالث على التوالي من قبل
المتمردين قلت انه في الساعات الاخيره
ونحن يعني
نحو على بعد نحو ساعتين ونصف من انتهاء
الهدنه ان لم تمدد هل قلت انه الاشتباكات
تزيد عاده في هذه الفتره لتحسين المواقع
هل لا يزال الامر على حاله كما تسمع
وتراقب من عندك في الخرطوم
الان هدوء بعد مغيب الشمس هدات الاشتباكات
وواضح انه
يقتنع الطرفين بما يرى اليوم
ولكن السيد انه الاسواق والمعمل المركزي
معمل ستاك اللي دخلته مجموعه من قوات
الدعم السريع هذا سيحدث هالما اذا لم يتم
ثلاثه هذا الامر وخروجهم من هذا المعمل
باسرع ما يمكن لكن
لانه في عينات طبعا في هذا المعمل سلمت
قبل اسبوع
والمرضى ينتظرون النتائج الدخول لهذا
الدعم السريع من اجل الاستفاده من الطوابق
الموجوده ومحاوله تصويب
مدافعهم
الرئاسي او القياده العامه بدون ان يعلموا
ان ان هذه العينات
تتسبب في كارثه بيولوجيا لانه خطير جدا
هذا الامر هذا ما حدث لامه مؤشر طبعا خطير
جدا ويدل على انه نتحدث مره اخرى عن
الرياضه والسيطره انه ما في اهداف محدده
ما في سيطره من الرئاسات وبالتالي اصبحوا
يتجولون فقط اينما وجدوا مكان يدخلوا او
يطلب دعم من السكان او يطلب من الاسواق
وهكذا
فهذا مؤشر على ان حرب الشوارع اصبحت الان
بدون اهداف بالنسبه للطرف الاخر القوات
المسلحه
وتركز حتى لا تحدث خسائر وسط المدنين
طيب سياده اللواء الان اي مبادره ترى انها
المرشحه ان تكون الانضج
وبدءا باي نقطه تحاور وهل يجب هذا على هذا
التحاور ان يشمل النقاط السياسيه ايضا
يعني مباشره يجلس تجلس كل الاطراف على
الطاوله واحده او لابد من ايجاد بعد وقف
اطلاق النار طبعا من ايجاد حل عسكري مده
لاستعاده الثقه بين الطرفين العسكريين ومن
ثم نعود الى الحديث في السياسه
المبادره الاكثر قربنا الان هي مبادره
تجهيزات والاتحاد الافريقي المشتركه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ما يعرف بالرباعيه لديهم
مجهود اخر لكن الايجاد هذا الافريقي هي
الاغرب
جهدان منفصلان اذا تماما
ولكن يلت في الهدف الهدف هو الان الجند
الاول اللي هو ايقاف وقت اطلاق النار يجلس
المناديب ويكون الجلسه الاولى يوافق اطلاق
النار مع تحديدا مواقع القوات وبالتالي
نكون في مراقبين
اذا تمت هذه الجوله بنجاحه وتم تطوير وقت
اطلاق النار الى وقف دائم بالتالي المرحله
القادمه هي معالجه الاثار الجزريه لهذه
الصراع ونعني هنا المرحله الثانيه اللي هي
المرحله السياسيه لكن هنا ملاحظه
تتغير الفاعلون ويتغير اللاعبون بناء على
هذا التمرد الذي حدث وبالتالي هو السياسيه
نفسها تتغير ربما تدخل اطراف لم تكن
موجوده في الاتفاق الايطالي هذا سيعدل
المساله تماما وبالتالي قد يكون هنالك
تغيير في مستقبل الحكم الديمقراطي وكيفيه
تكوين الحكومه المدنيه موضوع توسيع قاعده
المشاركه المدنيه تقصد
نعم توشيع المشاركه لانه في فاعلين الان
كان جزء من الازمه والان ليس لديهم وجود
على الساحه حتى لم يتدخلوا مع اطرافهم
كانت موجوده وهذا دليل على انه يجب توسيع
المشاركه يجب ادخال الفعاليات الشعبيه
المتضرره الان وبالتالي انا اتوقع انه
يكون في تغيير في الفاعلين واللاعبين
الرئيسيين حتى
الثلاثيه مستر فولكرم موجوده الان في
الخرطوم لم يغادر وبالتالي هو يحاول احداث
توازن ما بين القوه السياسيه الموجوده وما
بين اللاعبين الجدد بناء على مقتضيات هذا
الصراع لماذا التغيير يجب ان يكون فقط في
القوه المدنيه وليس في الوجوه العسكريه
التي ورطت البلاد في حرب عرفنا متى بدات
لا نعرف متى تنتهي
التغيير العسكري هو بيقوم بناء على نتائج
الوقفه النار والم الموجوده وكيف سيتم دمج
الدعم السريع هذه نقطه عسكريه فنيه لا
يمكن الحديث عنها الان الدعم السريعه
ما تبقى منه هل سيوافر على الدم هل ستكون
الفتره الزمنيه اقل
مساله الحل هل ستكون موجوده ام سيلغى هذا
القرار قرار الحل او تتحول غياته الى
قياده سياسيه بعد الدرس هذه امور فنيه
اعتقد انها في جلسه التفاوض الاولى
والثانيه يمكن حسمها من اجل المصلحه
العامه وليس من
المصالح الذاتيه اللواء دكتور امين
اسماعيل مسدوب الخبير الامني والاستراتيجي
بمركز دراسات دوليه من الخرطوم شكرا جزيلا
لك على هذه المشاركه معنا الليله تحياتي
اليك
[موسيقى]
تجدد القتال في اقليم دارفور المضطرب غرب
السودان يبدو انه اتخذ ابعادا قبليه معارك
عنيفه واشتباكات وصفتها الامم المتحده
بالدميه شهدتها مدينه الجنينه عاصمه ولايه
غرب دارفور وهي التي تشاهدونها على
الخريطه بين عناصر الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع مستخدمين مختلف انواع الاسلحه
القتال العنيف تحول الى نزاع بين قبيله
المساليت الافريقيه والقبائل العربيه
استخدمت فيه الاسلحه الثقيله عشرات القتلى
من المدنيين سقطوا كما لنا ان نتصور في
هذا الشرح المرئي ومئات الجرحى اصيبوا لم
يتم اسعافهم بسبب صعوبه الاوضاع الامنيه
وانتشار المسلحين القبليين في اجزاء واسعه
من مدينه الجنينه منطقه مضطربه دائما عدا
عن تزايد اعمال النهب للمؤسسات الحكوميه
ومقر المنظمات الامميه والسوق الجنينه
اضافه الى حرق عدد كبير من المنازل وفقه
مسؤولين في حكومه غرب دارفور ذلك الى جانب
توزيع الاسلحه بين المجتمعات المحليه ما
يزيد من الفوضى والعنف هذه التطورات دفعت
بعدد من سكان الجنينه الى الفرار باتجاه
الحدود السودانيه شاديه رغم اغلاق الحكومه
هناك للحدود حدود طويله جدا اذا بين
البلدين ومنطقه متوتره كما قلنا منذ عقدين
يعيش اقليم دارفور اضطرابات امنيه كبيره
تخللتها انتهاكات واسعه تسببت بمقتل قرابه
300 الف شخص مع نزوح مليونين ونصف المليون
شخص
[تصفيق]
اجرت العربيه مقابلات حول الجاليه
العراقيه التي عادت من السودان من داخل
مطار بغداد الدولي نتابعه اللي رجعنا هسه
احنا تقريبا 240 واحد لكن طبعا عندنا هناك
موجودين موجودين ظلوا عالقين والله ضلوا
عالقين
بالسودان للمسافات بعيده يعني اللي ساكن
بسناره صعب يوصل للخرطوم واللي ساكن
القضارف صعب يوصل يعني حركه التنقل في
اثناء المعارك تصير صعبه جدا صعبه الرحله
عامه مشيت بسلاسه بس هي طبعا المسافات
طويله من الخرطوم الى بورت السودان فوق 12
ساعه بالحافله
اكو يعني مثلا اماكن مشحونه ضرب ومضروب بس
احنا كنا قاعدين انا بالخرطوم
بالمكان اسمه
ضرب وقصف بس مو قريبه من يمك وصارت ظروف
الحرب طبعا وعشنا ايام صعبه والسوداني
برضو عاشوا ايام صعبه بس لما شفنا انه
بالتلفزيون الاجلاء لكل المواطنين الاجانب
اللي قاعدين يعني انبسطنا وقلنا ان شاء
الله هم يعني احنا يعني بنطلع والحمد لله
يعني سهلت امورنا وصلنا بالسلامه
معنا من بغداد دكتور احمد الصحافي المتحدث
الرسمي باسم وزاره الخارجيه العراقيه اهلا
بك معنا دكتور في هذه التغطيه كم عدد
الذين عادوا اذا تؤكد الرقم الذي ورد على
لسان احد افراد الجاليه من الذين عادوا او
العدد اكبر
تحيه وتقدير لحضراتكم العدد الذي احصيناه
بشكل دقيق هو
من افراد الجاليه العراقيه كان من دينهم
سته عشر مواطن من
الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه
اذا نحن نتحدث عن 234 عراقيا من يعني من
الذين عادوا من الذين احصيتموهم 16 مواطنا
سوريا بينهم عدد العالقين حتى الان هل
تمكنتم من احصائهم
نحن وجهنا نداء عاجلا لابناء الجاليه
العراقيه الكريمه وحددنا توقيتات ومواقع
محدده للانطلاق وصولنا الى النقطه
النهائيه التي منها يكون وهو مطار سودان
وبعض العراقيين افراد جدا محدودين لم
يتمكنوا من الوصول بسبب عدم توافق وسائل
النقل من جهه ومن جهه اخرى الوضع الامني
الذي اعاقهم عن الخروج من المساكنهم
والتوجه الى الموقع النهائي للاجلاء لكننا
بالتاكيد
تمرون بتلقي الاتصالات والاستجابه
لمناشداتهم والعمل جانم في غرفه
الاستجابه الدبلوماسيه الطارئه لتحقيق
استجابه ممكنه لهم
من داخل كيف تفعلون ذلك بمساعده دول اخرى
مثلا او او عبر اي قواعد ومطارات
ابدا الجهود عراقيه صرفه وبالتعاون مع
السلطات المعنيه في السودان هذه الرحله
التي كانت من الاجلاء كانت في الحقيقه
بجهود عراقيه تامه الطبابه العسكريه
وطائرات النقل الجوي العسكري وجهود وزاره
الخارجيه العراقيه للتنسيق
بغداد
والتنسيق والتعامل مع الجهات على الارض
هناك كلها ادت الى انجاح عمليه الاجلاء
التي
اعلناها جميعا معكم والان بالنسبه الى
العالقين اذا كان هناك اعداد لا تزال تريد
العوده ماذا عليها ان تفعل
لا نزال نتصل بهم بشكل مباشر وننسق مع
السلطات المعنيه هناك كما اننا نجري الان
التخطيط لمجموعه من الخيارات داخل غرفه
الاستجابه للدبلوماسيه الفارغه وتنسق مع
الجهات المعنيه في الحكومه العراقيه
لتحقيق استجابه ممكنه خلال وقت العاجل هل
كان هناك لا سمح الله قتله او جرح من
الجاليه العراقيه في السودان
سبق لنا ان اعلنا ان مواطن عراقيا واحدا
من ابناء الجاليه كان قد لقي حتفه
باطلاق
جراء الاشتباكات التي لا تزال مستمر في
السودان
الرسمي وحدده هويه المواطن العراقي
ولا نزال
نبحث عن اي معلومه تؤكد ان اعداد الاخرى
لكن لم يتاكد لدينا الرسميه سوى ان هذا
المواطن العراقي هو الذي لقيه حتفه اذا
نحن نؤكد فقط
مصرع مواطن عراقي واحد ولم وهناك تقارير
عن يعني قد يكون هناك اصابات او قتل اخرين
ولكن ليس لديكم معلومات مؤكده حتى الان
كما افدتنا انا قلت انا قلت بتحديد مواطن
واحد لقي احدفه ولم يتاكد لدينا باي
تقارير رسميه اخرى غير ذلك وانا اقول بعد
ما كلامك انقل عنك على لسانك بانه هذا
الكلام غير مؤكد هناك تقارير ولكن انتم
غير متاكدين منه طيب بخصوص من تبقى هناك
هل تعرفون اماكن تواجدهم هل هم في اماكن
مثلا خطيره حتى الان او في اماكن بعيده
ولكن تقطعت بهم السبل او ماذا
القسم الاغلب منهم يتواجدون في مناطق ليست
خطره لكنها نائيه وهذا ما اعاقهم في ان
يستقلوا وسائل
للتواصل
والاتصال وكذلك خطوط للنقل توصلهم الى
مطار بورت سودان نعمل الان على تحقيق
استجابه ممكنه من اجل التعرف على كامل
اعدادهم وتوفير ما يمكن لهم من اجل امنهم
وسلامتهم لكن المؤكد ان كل الذين رغبوا
بالاجلاء تم اجلائهم خلال الرحله التي
نفذت هذا اليوم
بخصوص الدبلوماسيين دكتور
العدد الكامل لطاقم سفاره جمهوريه العراق
في الخرطوم ولم يتبقى احد وبموجي بذلك اذا
ما قررنا ان نستجيب لاي مناشدات اخرى
فسنقوم
بتدابير لوجستيه من نوع معين لتحقيق هذه
الاستجابه هل تعرضت ايات مصالح عراقيه في
في السودان في هذه الحرب
يعني للاصابه للخطر السفاره القنصليات
المصالح شركات ما
التمثيل الدبلوماسي العراقي تمثيل مقيم
ومستقر في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
ونتيجه للاحداث والاشتباكات الجاريه الان
بين طرفين نزاع الان اجلي العدد الكامل
لطاقم السفاره الجمهوريه العراق
ومصالحنا هي تتمثل بالحفاظ على العلاقات
الثنائيه وهذا امر
مستدام ونعمل على تاكيده واصدرت الخارجيه
العراقيه بيانها الذي افادت بمضمونه دعوه
الطرفين لزاع الى اهميه الارتكان لطاوله
الحوار والعراق لن يدخر جهدا في تقديم اي
دعم وعون ومساعده فضلا عن الانضمام لايه
مبادرات من شانها ان تحد من اطلاق النار
وتنتهي بالصراع الجاري الى توافق وطني
سوداني يعزز الامن والاستقرار والسياده في
السودان شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور احمد الصحافه
المتحدث الرسمي باسمي وزاره الخارجيه
العراقيه من بغداد تحياتي اليك نتابع ما
لدينا
[موسيقى]
الى موجزه لاهم الاخبار الدوليه قبل ان
نتابع او نعود الى تغطيتنا حول السودان
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن توجيه ضربه
مركزه باسلحه بحريه عاليه الدقه على مواقع
تمركز احتياطات القوات الاوكرانيه وفي
السياق ذاتها افدت الدفاع الروسيه بان
قواتها سيطرت على عده مناطق جديده في
الضواحي الشماليه والجنوبيه لبخمت مؤكده
ان على الجيش الروسي على ان الجيش الروسي
ابسط سيطرته بالبسطها على اربعه احياء
جديده في مخموت
اعضاء الحلف قدموا دعما غير مسبوق
لاوكرانيا وان الدعم الغربي لاوكرانيا
سيجعلها بوضع قوي لمواصله استعاده اراضيها
بالتعاون مع الولايات المتحده قدما اعضاء
النيتو دعما غير مسبوق لاوكرانيا وتم
بالفعل تسليم اكثر من
98% من المركبات القتاليه التي وعدت بها
اوكرانيا وهذا يعني اكثر من
1550 عربه مدرعه و230 دبابه ومعدات اخرى
بما في ذلك كميات هائله من الذخيره كما
قمنا بتدريب وتجهيز اكثر من تسع كتائب
مدرعه اوكرانيه جديده وهذا سيضع اوكرانيا
في وضع قوي لمواصله استعاده اراضيها
المحتله اكد وزير الخارجيه الصينيه ان اول
محادثه هاتفيه بين الرئيس الصيني تشيجن
بينج ونظيره الاوكراني منذ بدء العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه
تعد خطوه مهمه نحو تسويه سياسيه للازمه
مشيرا الى ان الخطوه التي اتخذتها الصين
تمثل مدى التزام الدوله الثابت بالحياديه
قائلا ان موقف الصين يعزز عمليات السلام
والمفاوضات
اكد رئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان دول
الناميه تعاني اكثر من غيرها بسبب
العقوبات المفروضه على تصدير الاسمده
الروسيه مؤكدا خلال اجتماع مع رئيس
الرابطه الروسيه لمنتجي الاسمده ان
العقوبات على بلاده تم فرضها من قبل الدول
التي لا تحتاج الى الاسمده مشيرا الى ان
الاسواق الناميه في افريقيا وامريكا
اللاتينيه واسيا تضررت بشكل كبير
ظهر رئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان على شاشه
التلفزيون لاول مره بعد مرضه وذلك بحسب ما
نقلته وكاله
حيث شارك اردوغان في فيديو مباشر مع نظيره
حول مساهمه روسيا في انشاء محطه اكويو
للطاقه النوويه في جنوب تركيا
اعلنت البحريه الامريكيه ان الحرس الثوريه
الايراني احتجز ناقله نفط ترفع علم جزر
مارشال مطالبه بالافراج الفوري عنها وقال
الرسول الخامس للبحريه الامريكيه ان الحرس
الثوريه الايراني احتجز ناقله النفط اثناء
عبورها في المياه الدوليه في خليج عمان
مطالبا الحكومه الايرانيه بالافراج عنها
فورا بدورها قالت البحريه الايرانيه ان
الناقله حاولت الفرار بعد اصطدامها بزورق
ايراني ما اسفر عن فقدان شخصين واصابه
اخرين مشيره الى ان مدمره ايرانيه اوقفت
ناقله واقتادتها للسواحل الايرانيه
تدرس الحكومه البلجيكيه تسليما دبلوماسي
ايراني محكوم بالسجن الى ايران وقال رئيس
الوزراء البلجيكي ان حكومته تدرس طلبا
ايرانيا بتسليم الدبلوماسيه الايراني اسد
الله اسد المحكوم بالسجن 20 عاما مقابل
افراز طهران عن عامل اغاثه بلجيكي يقضي
عقوبه السجن لمده اربعين عاما بتهمه
التجسس وادين اسد بالتخطيط لهجوم على تجمع
معارض لنظام طهران في فرنسا عام 2018
تبنى مجلس النواب الباكستاني مشروعه قرار
بتاكيد الثقه التامه برئيس الوزراء محمد
شهباس شريف كزعيم للاغلبيه النيابيه
ورئيسا للحكومه الائتلافيه وحصل شهباز
شريف على تاييد اغلبيه اعضاء مجلس النواب
بدعم 180 نائبا من اصل
342 وهو عدد مقاعد مجلس النواب المطلوب
لتاكيد الثقه كما يعد هذا العدد اكبر من
مجموع الاصوات التي حصل عليها شريف عند
حصوله على ثقه مجلس النواب شهر ابريل عام
الماضي حيث حصل على
174 صوتا
صددت الشرطه الفرنسيه حشدا من المتظاهرين
المناهضين لاصلاح نظام التقاعد قرابه احد
القصور في شرق فرنسا ويوجد الرئيس
ايمانيويل مكروه في هذا القصر الذي يقع
على الحدود الفرنسيه سويسريه للاحتفال
بالذكرى المئه والخامسه 175 لالغاء الرق
في فرنسا
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
ان الرئيس الامريكي الحالي جو بايدن يشكل
خطرا على الديمقراطيه واضاف ترامب على
صفحته على موقع
ان بايدن غير كفء ولا يعرف كيف يدير
البلاد واعتبر الرئيس السابق ان الولايات
المتحده في حاله تدهور خطير بسبب قياده
شخص عديم الجدوى على حد تعبيره
وعوده لرصد الموقف في السودان والموقف
الامريكي منه تحديدا نذهب الى البيت
الابيض مباشره ينضم الينا من هناك جون
كيربي منسق شؤون الاتصالات في مجلس الامن
القومي اهلا بك معنا سيد كوربي على شاشه
العربيه هل هناك مبادره امريكيه متكامله
حاليا للعمل على وقف اطلاق النار
يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال بمناسبه شؤون
الاتصالات في مجلس الامن القومي اذا هناك
طبعا العديد من الاخبار العاجله التي كانت
وردت في خلال الساعات الماضيه نحن على بعد
ساعتين تقريبا فقط من انتهاء الهدنه التي
كانت قائمه لمده 72 ساعه ومن بدايه مفترضه
غير مؤكده لهدنه جديده 72 ساعه اخرى تعمل
عليها بعض الدول الجيش اكد التزامه بها
ولكن قوات الدعم السريع حتى الان لم تؤكد
دعمها طبعا الجيش السوداني كان قال بان
المتمردين ارتكبوا فضائع في حق سكان بري
الدراسي بالخرطوم وان استمرار القصف
والقنص العشوائي على منطقه القياده العامه
بالخرطوم ومحيطها هو سيد الموقف كان قال
ان الهدنه تم خرقها لليوم الثالث على
التوالي من قبل المتمردين اما البيت
الابيض فكان ابدى تشاؤما هذه الليله قائلا
بانه حركنا قوه بحريه الى المنطقه لتقديم
اي دعم عند الحاجه بسبب الوضع في السودان
وانه ينسق لاج الامريكيين من السودان
بمساعده المملكه العربيه السعوديه وعلى
الامريكيين الراغبين بمغادره السودان
استغلال الفرصه خلال اليومين المقبلين
البيت الابيض قال ان الوضع السوداني قد
يزداد سوءا في اي لحظه هناك مطالبا الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع باحترام وقف
اطلاق النار بشكل كامل اما البانتاجون
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه من جهتها فكانت
قالت بانه اعداد الامريكيين الراغبين في
مغادره السودان قليله نسبيا الجيش
السوداني اذا كان تحدث عن تمديد الهدنه
الاثنتين وسبعين ساعه نسال جونكر الان
الذي يعود الينا منسق شؤون الاتصالات في
مجلس الامن القومي اهلا بك معنا
جيدا هل هناك مبادره امريكيه حاليا لوقف
اطلاق النار في السودان
وقبل وزاره الخارجيه يتراسها السيد بلينكل
لتمديد بوقف اطلاق النار في الايام
المقبله لقد راينا تخفيضا في اعمال العنف
التي طالت كافه انحاء السودان لكن هناك
بعض المناطق التي لا تزال فيها اعمال
العنف لكن مع ذلك تراجع العنف ونعمل بصوره
حديثه للتواصل مع الطرفين من اجل تمديد
وقف اطلاق النار هل استطعتم التحصل على
موافقه الطرفين على تمديد الهدنه التي
تنتهي بعد ساعتين من الان الاثنتين وسبعين
ساعه اخرى
على درايه بالاجل النهائي للهدنه الحاليه
ونعمل مع الطرفين المتحاربين الجنرال
البرهان والجنر الحميتي لتمديد وقف اطلاق
النار لان هذا هو الامر الصائب الذي يجب
فعله من اجل الشعب السوداني ومن اجل
الرعايه الاجانب الذي الذين يعيشون في
السودان وكذلك للاحتياجات الانسانيه في
السودان هل مبادرتكم منفصله عن مبادره
الايجاد او جهودكم بالاحرى هل هي منفصله
يمكن ان اتحدث عن جهود اخرى تماما او انكم
ترحبون بمبادره الايجاد
اننا نرحب بمبادره ايجاد او اي مبادره
اخرى من اجل وقف القتال وادخال المساعدات
الانسانيه الولايات المتحده توسطت في وقف
اطلاق النار الذي شهدناه على مر الساعات
الاثنتين وسبعين الماضيه واننا سعيدون
لرؤيه ذلك لكننا بكل تاكيد نرحب بجهود
كافه الحلفاء وشركاء من اجل احلال السلام
في السودان ان لم يحصل ذلك وان لم يتفق
الطرفان في وقت مبكر هل
تهددون بامكانيه فرض عقوبات على احد
الطرفين او على كلا الطرفين
انا لن استبق الاحداث والخيارات التي قد
نتبعها او لا نتبعها لكن ما استطيع ان
اخبرك اياه بان التركيز في الفتره الحاليه
ينصب على وقف القتال
واستمرار وقف القتال بحيث يمكن ادخال
للمساعده الانسانيه والناس الذين يرغبون
بالمغادره بمقدورهم فعل ذلك وكذلك الضمان
عوده السلم والامان للشعب السوداني هذا ما
يبحث عن الشعب السوداني وهذا ما نريده لهم
لكن التركيز الان ينصب على وقف العنف
طيب هل تتفهمون هل تتفهمون اسباب الحرب
التي يعلنها كل طرف من الطرفين طرف الجيش
وطرف قوات الدعم السريع
هل لك هل تتفهمون في الولايات المتحده
الاسباب التي يقول بها كل طرف حول
محاربته الطرف الاخر وقوه دعم السعري الان
توافق على الهدنه تفضل
سوف ادفع اتركه الجنرالات لتتحدث عن
وجهاتي النظر والاختلافات فيما بينهما
وحول كيفيه التعامل مع الاوضاع في السودان
من المؤكد ان لكل منهما رؤيه مختلفه حول
مستقبل السودان بمقدورهم التحدث عن ذلك
لكن بالنسبه لنا نرغب بوقف العنف والقاء
السلاح بحيث نستطيع ان نحقق السلام
والاستقرار لادخال المساعدات الانسانيه
للناس المحتاجين اذا كان الطرفان
المتحاربان يهتمان البته بمستقبل السودان
فلابد لهم من وقف السلاح من القاء السلاح
ووقف القتال وايجاد ايجاد السبل لاسقالي
الغذاء والمياه والمعدات الطبيه والتحول
الى سلطه مدنيه في البلاد
يسال ما الحكمه الامريكيه في المساواه بين
طرفي القتال بينما الجيش السوداني هو
القوات المسلحه السودانيه وهو النظام
السوداني القائم حاليا واتهاماته للطرف
الاخر بانه اشبه بمليشيات لماذا تساوون
بين الطرفين
اود ان اوضح هنا اننا لا ندخل انفسنا ولا
نزجوا بانفسنا في هذه الحرب
بل نسعى للتفاوض
في الفتره الحاليه الى تسويه في الفتره
المستقبليه وما نسعى للقيام به هي مساله
بسيطه ان نطلب من الطرفين المتحاربين
العمل على وقف القتال وان يلتزمان وقد
التزم الطرف الطرفان بوقف القتال في
الساعات اثنتين وسبعين الماضيه وقد انخفض
مستوى العنف لدى من غير المقبول اذا ما
كان هناك
سعي لوقف اطلاق نار دعم فلا بد من التحدث
الى الطرفين وليس الى طرف واحد هذا ما
نعمل عليه ما الدور الذي تقوم به السعوديه
في هذا الاطار وهل هي المرشحه الاكبر فعلا
لاستضافه فريقي النزاع السيد البرهان
ويعني زعيمين الفريقين السيد البرهان
والسيد حميدتي على اراضيها لاجراء مفاوضات
هل يمكن تاكيد ذلك
من المؤكد بانني سوف اترك شركائنا
واصدقائنا في السعوديه للحديث عن ذلك
لكنهم قد ساعدونا الى حجم كبير في اجلائي
مواطنين امريكيين وقد ساعدوا ايضا
في اجلاء اعداد كبيره من الرعايه الاجانب
عبر بورسودان وقد تكون السعوديه وقد يكون
للسعوديه دور مهم في اجلائي اعداد كبيره
من الاجانب واننا ممتنون لما تقوم به في
هذا الخصوص شكرا جزيلا للاتصالات في مجلس
الامن القومي من واشنطن تحياتي اليك
نعود الان الى استكمال تغطيه التطورات
الاحداث في السودان مع صهيب شرعي الى
اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات